hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds I'm
a property investor and firstly thank
you so much for coming to this video I
hope you are a subscriber of the channel
and I want to be teaching a strategy
right now this is a property investment
strategy called rent to rent now if
you've been watching my videos for a
long time you've probably heard me
talking about this before you may have
seen me securing rent to rent deals or
working with my students and seeing them
securing rent to rent deals but I
recently did a video where I talked
about the seven property investment
strategies because when most people
think of investing in property or being
a property entrepreneur they think of
saving up money working really hard over
the years and then buying a investment
property that they rent out now the
great thing about rent to rent and I'm
gonna give you the good and the bad in
this video by the way but the great
thing about rent around is you don't
actually own the property which means
you don't need to buy the property which
means that you don't have to save up for
years
to get the deposit that's why so many
people are attracted to rent to rent so
what exactly is rent to rent it's when
you rent a property under a business
management agreement so you don't rent a
property to live in you rent it off of a
landlord on a management agreement so
you're paying a monthly rent to the
landlord now because you're paying a
monthly rent to the landlord on a
management agreement you're not living
there it means that the landlord doesn't
have any costs the landlord doesn't have
to pay a manager because you are the
manager normally when you rent a
property the landlord is going to get
the rent but these enough to pay
management costs he's also gonna have to
pay maintenance costs guess what as the
manager of the property you're going to
take care of the maintenance you're
going to take care of the management
also the landlord might be worried that
he has void periods tenants moving in
and moving out spots of seasons where
there's no tenant in there and then he
has to just get paid nothing
so because you're offering the landlord
a guaranteed rent on this management
agreement where you're the manager
you're gonna give a reduced rent you're
gonna pay him as small as you possibly
can where the landlord is still happy
you're also gonna do this on a property
that you know has potential
to change its use and massively increase
the rent and you do this by turning it
into a property that is a HMO for
instance where you rent it out on a
room-by-room basis or you do this by
turning it into a serviced accommodation
unit so you rent each room out or you
rent the whole thing out when you do it
on very short let's on Airbnb on
booking.com
so as a rent to renter what you're doing
is you're paying the landlord let's say
500 pound a month but you're renting the
property out maximum rent for let's say
2000 pound a month and if you're a
skeptic right now you might be thinking
how on earth would you rent it out for
two thousand pound a month and only pay
the landlord 500 because you've changed
the use you you're renting out room by
room by room by room or you're renting
it out short stays for a hundred pound a
night where is that the landlord he's
just getting a long-term monthly rent
and you might think well why would the
landlord not just do that himself and
the answer is because number one the
landlord might not have the knowledge
how to do it he might not have the time
he might have the inclination he might
have bad misconceptions seen some
negative press around serviced
accommodation or something like that he
just wants to get his monthly management
fee he doesn't want that but you as the
entrepreneur as the rent to renter you
maximize the rent now from your point of
view as the rent to renter and again I'm
going to talk about the good and the bad
in a minute now I'm just explaining what
the strategy is but you was the rent to
renter you've put down very little money
maybe even no money or you might have
had to pay a little bit for the
furniture or things like that to change
the use but you want to put down as
little money as possible and then every
single month you're keeping that monthly
profit so renter it's a very successful
strategy with many of my students you
can make anywhere between I'd sound you
want to be making a minimum of five
hundred pounds a month profit per
property that you do on a rent to rent
so you've got four or five of those
unless we place the average salary so
you can very easily replace an average
salary by having a small portfolio of
rent to rents
and you don't own them you control them
same as uber don't own their cars and
Amazon doesn't own most of its stock and
Airbnb doesn't own its properties as a
rent to renter your being a property
entrepreneur and you're controlling the
properties but not only them that's what
it is question should you do it firstly
let me tell you why you should not do it
these are the reasons that you shouldn't
do it number one do not do it if you
think this is going to be get-rich-quick
it's not getting rich quick
this is get financially free over a
period of time so if you think you're
going to suddenly easily make you know
tens and tens of thousands of pounds a
month within within we were very little
effort very little work within a few
weeks it's probably not really going to
happen so it's not get rich quick set
your expectations right this is a
business and you need to treat it like a
business
number two you shouldn't do this
strategy if you're not prepared to roll
your sleeves up and work hard this is
gonna be pretty tough because in the
early days you're gonna have to
negotiate with the landlord's you're
gonna get told no you're gonna get
people saying why would we you know you
can take all these objections and unless
you are prepared to work and be
persistent this isn't really gonna be
for you this is going to take work is it
impossible of course not but it's gonna
take some work next you shouldn't do
this if you're not prepared to take any
risk there is a level of risk within
rent to rents because if you're paying
the landlord a monthly fee on the basis
that you're then going to rent the
property out for a higher rent and make
cash flow that's great and if you do
your due diligence that that will happen
but there's a chance that you'll pay the
landlord a guaranteed monthly rent and
then you'll struggle to rent the rooms
out especially if you've not done your
due diligence so you've not been trained
properly on the strategy and if that
happens you could you could potentially
be at a loss now you can put break
clauses in with the landlord to give you
an opportunity to walk away but there's
a chance that you could lose money doing
this you could definitely lose time so
if you're not there to take any risk
then maybe you'd be better off working
in a job because if you're working in on
the job there's there's very very little
risk apart from getting fired or being
made redundant you're being an
by very definition your your stepping
out taking risk in the hope to make a
profit so don't do this if you're not
prepared to take any risk both in terms
of time and financial so those are all
the reasons why not to do it last reason
I'll say why not to do it as well as
whilst this is simple went to rent is
straightforward there are certain
legalities that you need to learn there
are certain things that you need to know
so I probably wouldn't do this unless
you're prepared to learn if you are not
prepared to spend time and money in your
education any profession any business if
you want to be a hairdresser you have to
go to college to learn how to cut hair
if you want to be a doctor you have to
get a university to learn how to be a
doctor I believe if you want to be a
property entrepreneur and you want to
learn about rent events I believe that
you should in the same way you should
study that craft and you should learn
that it's not going to take four years
it's not going to cost you forty
thousand pound like a lot of
universities but there is gonna be some
investment in knowledge that's why I've
put together a rent to rent training
course which you might want to check out
and I'll leave some a link in the
description about that but you have to
study the craft so those are all the
reasons why you should not do rent to
rent here are the reasons why you should
do rector and and I life personally I'm
an entrepreneur so I would say this I
think that the the reasons why you
should probably outweigh the reasons
that you shouldn't the reasons that you
should are number one it is very little
money down whilst there might be a
little bit of money needed up front
maybe you might have to pay the landlord
a little bit of money up front rent
there might be some properties that you
have to furnish and spend a few hundred
or a few thousand pounds even it's very
very little money and in terms of a
business most businesses that you want
to start they will require startup funds
generally speaking and normally if you
only need a very small amount of 'men
start up a business let's say you only
need three thousand pounds to start a
business it's probably because the
reward is very small as well so you pay
three thousand pounds you get your
little business box startup but then
actually it you only have the capacity
to make twenty or thirty thousand pounds
a year whereas rent to rent you need
very very little money to start little
bit of money to educate yourself a
little bit of money to put down on the
properties but all even
little bit of money to put down the
reward is huge a lot of my students are
making tens of thousands of pounds in
recurring income every single month from
their rent to rent properties a lot of
my students that have learned the rent
to rent formula they leave their jobs
they replace their income from their
corporate jobs within a matter of two or
three months
that's how possible this is so the
reward verse the risk is very very good
so the first reason is because the
downpayment in this business is very
very small second reason why I think you
potentially should consider rent to
rents is because the experience that you
get as a property investor it's almost
like try before you buy if you want to
be a property investor when you want to
buy houses and rent them out and you're
saving up to do that to start building
your property portfolio doing rent to
rent you're gonna get all the experience
of the area's what areas work best how
to get a really high rent in different
properties so that when you come to
build your own portfolio you're going to
know exactly what to buy what's gonna
give you the best rent one of the best
areas who are the best management
companies you're gonna be in a really
good position to do that and if you if
you turn a single out property and you
push the rent up and then you rent it
out as a house of multiple occupancy as
a HM out by renting out room by room and
you think that was cool when you're
making cash flow what are you probably
going to start doing buying properties
that you rent out in the exact same way
so the second reason is because the
experience that you get why I think you
should do read to rents the third reason
I think you should do rent amounts is
because I believe it's the fastest way
to become financially independent I mean
certainly within property I mean you can
you can do lots of different the seven
different strategies but rent to rent if
you want to get a recurring income
coming in starting with nothing all very
very little
I believe rent to it's the fastest way
that you can do that you can but you can
rent a property which might take a
couple of weeks if you know what you're
doing
boom then then to give the landlord a
small ramp put tenants in it's so fast
the money comes in so fast so I think
the speed the experience
you get the low startup charge and it's
the return on investment fourthly the
return on investment when when you're an
investor you're looking at what am i
putting down what am I getting back how
much did I have to put down to buy the
house how much am i renting it out for
and you calculate the two you divide
them together that gives you your return
on investment a lot of investors out
there look for about 10 percent return
on investment now all I look for higher
than that but rent to rent how much you
actually put in down in cash probably a
few thousand pounds how much you make in
each month a lot of rent events make a
thousand pound a month profit which is
twelve thousand pound a year divide that
together and it's like three hundred
percent or more so the return on
investment sky-high
it's easy to get into and get started
the amount of money that you need is
very small and it's the fastest way I
believe to become financially
independent so I hope that's given you a
little bit of a lowdown around what rent
to rent is how it works if you've got
questions comment your questions below
and I'll do my best to try and answer
your your questions or do another video
follow-up video with more detail if you
enjoyed this video please do system
match the like button if you want to see
more videos like this don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and turn on the
notification valve you do not miss a
video update thanks so much for watching
I'll see you next time
peace out